[Música]
antes del mundo de los humanos existía
el de los dioses un reino de Campos
praderas y jardines en este ámbito
cuatro hermanos vagaban errantes solo se
tenían el uno al otro incluso
desconocían Quiénes eran sus padres uno
de los hermanos de Milán era distinto a
los demás tenía la piel cubierta de
dolorosas costras y se preguntaba por
qué era el único condenado a esta
afección un día mientras ya haya el
espíritu supremo se encontraba en el
jardín de Milán y sus hermanos se
metieron en su casa
tras darse un festín y revisar el lugar
vieron una gran calabaza al intentar ver
Su contenido la vasija se les cayó por
accidente la calabaza se hizo añicos y
surgió un torrente de agua que los
arrastró y desterró para siempre de ese
reino celestial las aguas que emanaron
de la calabaza formaron un nuevo mundo
uno cubierto de mares inexistentes en el
mundo de los dioses
los mares rebosaban de peces y otras
criaturas con Islas y Cuevas esparcidas
por doquier este mundo de mares también
fue separado de las tierras celestiales
y los hermanos vagaron errantes aún más
desorientados que en su mundo anterior
un día tres de los hermanos encontraron
una casa habitada por un anciano llamado
bayamanaco quien los invitó a entrar
temirán llegó algo más tarde e ingresó
también a la casa
vaya manáco se presentó como el abuelo
de los hermanos y les obsequió un pan de
yuca muy especial el anciano les reveló
su linaje familiar la madre había sido
la diosa madre tierra y tiva caubaba
Quien murió al nacer ellos los hermanos
le agradecieron la hospitalidad y el
relato de su descendencia pero
bayamanaco lanzó de su nariz una
mucosidad de tabaco que acabó en la
espalda de de Milán la piel afectada por
la agresión comenzó a inflamarse y a
causarle gran ardor Poco después de
Milán empezó a delirar y tanto se agravó
la inflamación de su espalda que los
hermanos temieron por su vida sin saber
a qué recurrir le hicieron un corte en
la piel de la incisión salió tortugas
que se alejó nadando abriéndose paso con
facilidad entre la Tierra y el mar
cuando de Milán se recuperó del delirio
finalmente comprendió la maldición de su
enfermedad era un caracol capaz de
comunicarse con los dioses oficiaba de
nexo entre el reino celestial y el reino
terrestre
de Milán fue el primero de la larga
estirpe de los caracoles
el mundo de los mares se transformó en
el mundo de los humanos donde los
caracoles que siguieron a demián
mantuvieron un delicado equilibrio entre
los humanos y los dioses
pero ese poder especial tuvo su precio
de Milán y los caracales posteriores
sufrieron la maldición de esa enfermedad
que inicialmente lo había distinguido de
sus hermanos
representado en grabados y estatuillas
taínas con una espalda inflamada y
escuálidos brazos el caracaracol es
tomado como bendición y también como
maldición por intermediar entre los
mundos
desea más mitos en este vídeo profundice
en el mito Azteca del enfermo y débil
naáhuatl que se eleva para convertirse
en el señor sol o descubra como el
poderoso Ford obtuvo su querido Martillo
mionir con este video